Salut les Épicurieuses et les Épicurieux.
Bienvenue dans cette vidéo
spéciale Halloween.
Aujourd'hui, je vais vous raconter cinq
histoires de monstres légendaires et terrifiants
et je ne suis pas allé les chercher
de l'autre côté de la Manche
ou de l'Atlantique.
Ils rôdent tout près de chez vous.
La Came-cruse
qui sévit dans le Sud-Ouest, la redoutable
Ganipote en Charente-Maritime,
les lavandières de nuit en Bretagne,
l'abominable petit homme rouge à Paris
et l'horrible Craqueuhhe en Lorraine.
Bienvenue dans le tour de France
des monstres légendaires. Brrrrr !
Imaginez : vous vous promenez
tranquillement sur un chemin
quand soudain, surgit une jambe, une jambe
sans corps qui se dirige vers vous.
Un oeil au niveau du genou
et deux espèces de bras
qui partent du milieu de la cuisse.
Elle vous regarde fixement d'un oeil
menaçant et elle s'élance vers vous !
À cloche pied, forcément !
Ça me rappelle la famille Adams !
La chose.
Cette chose, c'est la Came-cruse.
Une créature bien connue
dans tout le Sud-Ouest de la France.
Le jour, elle dort
cachée derrière les meules de foin,
mais lorsqu'elle se réveille à la tombée
de la nuit, elle n'a plus qu'un objectif :
dévorer tout crus
les malheureux qui croisent sa route.
D'où son nom : Came-cruse,
que l'on peut traduire par viande crue.
D'où vient cette histoire ?
Probablement d'un vieux conte agenais
qu'on se racontait autrefois, le soir,
au coin du feu, pour se faire peur.
Je vous pitche l'histoire.
Un jour, la femme d'un homme
très riche tombe et se brise la jambe.
Pour la remplacer,
son mari lui fait faire une jambe en or.
Au bout de sept ans,
la femme meurt
et on l'enterre avec sa précieuse jambe.
Quelque temps plus tard,
un valet décide de profaner la tombe
pour subtiliser la jambe.
Une voix féminine se fait
alors entendre dans tout le cimetière.
"D'or, d'or, rendez-moi ma jambe d'or !"
Le valet, un peu inquiet,
demande : "Que voulez-vous, madame ?"
Et la femme surgit de sa tombe en hurlant :
"C'est toi que je veux !"
Puis elle l'entraîne dans son trou
et le dévore. Depuis, une jambe
avide de chair fraîche, hanterait la région,
en terrorisant les habitants.
En 2021, un jeu a été organisé
sur TikTok : le gîte de la Came-Cruse.
Comme quoi, le temps passe,
mais les légendes restent.
On remonte un tout petit peu au Nord,
en Charente-Maritime.
C'est dans ce beau département bordé
par l'océan Atlantique,
mais aussi dans une bonne partie du Poitou
jusqu'en Touraine,
que l'on cultive
le mythe de la Ganipote.
Un joli nom qui peut prêter à sourire.
Pourtant, ne vous y fiez pas,
c'est un monstre !
Ceux qui disent l'avoir vue prétendent
qu'elle ressemble à un chien.
Son nom, Ganipote,
signifiant "patte de chien".
Il s'agirait plus exactement d'un croisement
entre un grand chien blanc et une louve.
L'animal serait pourvu de puissantes
griffes, une sorte de loup-garou.
Comme lui, on dit que les nuits sans lune,
la Ganipote hanterait les bois sombres.
Elle s'attaquerait
aux promeneurs en leur sautant sur le dos,
toutes griffes dehors.
Elle s'y agrippe et les fait chuter
et pèse de tout son poids
jusqu'à ce qu'ils périssent étouffés
La Ganipote peut aussi prendre l'apparence
d'un cheval,
d'un mouton, d'un bœuf ou d'un porc.
C'est là qu'elle est le plus redoutable.
Les enfants ne s'en méfient pas.
Elle en profiterait pour les attirer,
puis les entraîner dans les bois
et les dévorer.
Cette créature maléfique
a cependant un point faible. Écoutez bien,
ça peut vous sauver la peau.
Elle a peur de la lumière.
Pour l'éloigner, on recommandait autrefois
de poser sur les fenêtres des betteraves
évidées, éclairées de l'intérieur
par une bougie.
Moi la betterave,
même dans l'assiette, ça me fait peur !
Ça ne vous rappelle rien ?
Les citrouilles d'Halloween, bien sûr,
et la légende de Jack O'Lantern.
Évidemment, la Ganipote
est un animal légendaire.
Toutefois, de nombreuses personnes
en Charente-Maritime assurent
que leur grand-père ou leur grand-mère
aurait déjà croisé son chemin.
Ont-ils confondu avec un gros chien ?
C'est plus que probable !
La réalité, c'est que ce monstre
a été inventé de toutes pièces
pour faire peur aux enfants.
Un prétexte plutôt efficace
pour les dissuader
de sortir la nuit sans y être autorisés.
J'allais oublier :
si vous vous rendez
un jour à Saint-Palais-sur-Mer,
en Charente-Maritime,
vous passerez peut-être par la célèbre
avenue de la Ganipote.
Je vous rassure, personne
ne l'a jamais croisée sur les trottoirs.
Ça va, vous tenez le coup ?
Alors direction la Bretagne,
le pays des lavandières de nuit.
Une légende raconte qu'il
vaut mieux ne pas croiser leur chemin.
Autrefois, dans les villages,
elles s'occupaient de laver le linge
au lavoir. Elles le frottaient avec du savon,
puis le tordaient
et le frappaient avec un battoir
pour l'essorer. Mais en Bretagne,
on raconte qu'après leur décès, certaines
revenaient la nuit parmi les vivants.
Elles signalent leur présence en frappant
du linge à grands coups de battoir.
On dit que celui ou celle
qui osait s'aventurer
dehors avait alors toutes les chances
de voir sa dernière heure arriver.
Les lavandières
s'approchaient avec un grand sourire
en demandant de l'aide pour le lavoir,
mais une chemise ou un drap mal essoré
et votre sort était scellé !
Les lavandières de nuit
vous sautaient à la gorge
et vous étranglaient avec un drap mouillé.
Même pas peur !
J'ai un lave-linge.
Je vous rassure, on n'a jamais rapporté
la moindre preuve de leur existence.
Je vous le rappelle, c'est une légende.
En revanche, on a peut être
une explication sur son origine.
C'est l'écrivaine George Sand, qui n'était
pourtant pas bretonne mais berrichonne,
qui en parle le mieux dans un recueil
intitulé "Légendes rustiques",
publié en 1858.
Les lavandières de nuit seraient,
je cite : "les âmes des mères infanticides.
Elles battent et tordent incessamment
quelque chose qui ressemble à
du linge mouillé, mais qui, vu de près,
n'est qu'un cadavre d'enfant".
Autrement dit, cette histoire aurait été
inventée de toutes pièces pour effrayer
les femmes qui envisageaient d'avoir
recours à un avortement clandestin.
Fort heureusement, les temps ont changé.
Mais vous le savez,
les légendes ont la vie dure.
Et on dit en Bretagne que les anciens
évitent toujours, à la nuit
tombée, de s'approcher des lavoirs.
Le Sud-Ouest,
la Bretagne, Paris aussi héberge
ses créatures de légende.
Vous avez bien sûr
entendu parler du fantôme de l'Opéra.
Connaissez-vous le petit homme
rouge ? Non ?
Eh bien, vous avez de la chance.
Vous connaissez bien sûr
le jardin des Tuileries.
Autrefois, un palais s'y
dressait dans le prolongement du Louvre.
Il a été détruit par un incendie le 23 mai
1871 pendant la Commune de Paris.
Ce que l'on sait moins, c'est qu'il
aurait abrité un fantôme sanguinaire,
le fameux petit homme rouge.
Cette étonnante histoire commence en 1564.
Catherine de Médicis, alors
régente du royaume de France,
décide de se faire construire
un palais en bord de Seine.
Pour cela, elle fait détruire d'anciennes
fabriques de tuiles désaffectées.
Jusque là, tout va bien.
Le problème, c'est
qu'à deux pas, se trouve un abattoir
qui appartient à un certain Jean l'Écorcheur,
un boucher désosseur.
Le genre de gars
qu'il ne faut pas chercher.
Avec la régente, ils se connaissent bien.
On dit qu'elle faisait régulièrement
appel à lui pour se débarrasser
des cadavres un peu encombrants...
Eh bien, c'est du joli !
Le boucher accepte de partir
contre une importante somme d'argent,
ce qu'on lui refuse.
Il menace alors de tout balancer.
Mauvaise idée.
Pour qu'il se taise à jamais,
Catherine de Médicis le fait assassiner.
L'histoire s'arrête
là où la légende commence.
Peu après, la victime serait apparue à
Côme Ruggieri, l'astrologue de la reine
sous la forme d'une silhouette
sanguinolente. Il lui aurait confié
que son assassinat allait
entraîner la fin de la dynastie des Valois
et que Saint-Germain verrait mourir
Catherine de Médicis.
Or, il se trouve que le château
des Tuileries se trouve justement
sur les terres de la
paroisse de Saint-Germain l'Auxerrois.
Pour conjurer le sort,
la régente aurait donc décidé
de quitter son palais
en construction pour s'installer à Blois,
loin de Saint-Germain.
Mais des années plus tard,
le 5 janvier 1589, alors qu'elle
n'a plus que quelques heures à vivre,
on appelle un prêtre à son chevet.
Et devinez quoi ?
Il s'appelle Julien de Saint-Germain.
La légende du petit homme rouge
est en marche et vous allez voir
qu'elle va perdurer pendant des siècles.
Comme il l'avait prédit,
les trois fils de Catherine de Médicis
meurent successivement sans héritier mâle.
La dynastie des Valois disparaît
au profit des Bourbons.
Et ce n'est pas tout.
Ce fantôme sanguinolent n'aurait jamais
cessé de hanter nos rois de France.
On l'aurait croisé aux Tuileries
la veille de l'assassinat de Henri IV.
Marie-Antoinette
l'aurait aussi aperçu plusieurs fois,
notamment le 10 août 1792,
quand la foule a envahi les Tuileries.
Il serait même apparu à Napoléon
en personne
quelques jours
avant la bataille de Waterloo.
Sa toute dernière apparition
se serait produite le jour de l'incendie
du palais des Tuileries.
Cet événement lui aurait été,
semble-t-il fatal puisque depuis,
personne ne l'a jamais croisé.
On termine notre tour de France avec
le Craqueuhhe. C'est pas facile à prononcer !
J'espère qu'il ne m'en voudra pas.
En tout cas, en Lorraine,
on le craint comme le diable.
Les habitants de la Moselle le décrivent
sous la forme d'un vampire anthropophage,
une sorte de croque-mitaine
avec d'énormes mâchoires,
des dents de loup
et une barbe broussailleuse.
Son truc à lui, c'est
de guetter les enfants pour les dévorer,
un peu comme la Ganipote
dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure.
Toutefois, ces deux créatures ne partagent pas
le même territoire de chasse.
Le Craqueuhhe attend ses proies dans un lieu
plutôt inattendu : au fond des puits.
Les petits Lorrains étaient prévenus
à l'époque
où les maisons étaient toutes équipées
d'un puits.
S'ils désobéissent à leurs parents
et se penchaient par-dessus la margelle,
le Craqueuhhe les saisissait
et les noyait.
Vous le voyez, les monstres,
ça sert aussi à faire comprendre
aux enfants
que le monde est rempli de dangers.
C'est tout pour aujourd'hui,
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu.
Je suis curieux de savoir
quelle histoire vous fascine
le plus, ou vous fait le plus peur ?
Dites-le moi en commentaire.
Excellente semaine à toutes et à tous.
Pas de cauchemars ! Et à dimanche prochain.